capitalism has been the greatest reducer
of poverty the greatest creator of
wealth and education yeah and they're
trying to tear it down so think about
where we're at so far with our
constitutional republic and capitalistic
system no now we're not allows a fair
capitalism you know we got we got
regulation we got the Fed we got a bunch
of things people complain about but
think about what this has hath wrought
we've got civil rights legislation we've
got you know same-sex marriage you it
seems like an adoption you know
interracial marriage since the 60s
like we've come a long way man we really
have and things are only getting better
yeah it's like I was saying like you're
not allowed to be wrong you're not
allowed to admit you're wrong you're not
allowed to learn that's the biggest
thing actually you're not allowed to
learn so you take someone who who
doesn't realize that who's been
sheltered their whole life their family
was super racists you know like because
it exists in the past you know so here
we are down the line and then this
person goes out into the world and
someone goes oh your family was racist
well f you I'm never gonna ever speak to
you ever and they're like what just
happened I don't even know like you seem
like a nice person but now I think
you're kind of an a-hole you know but
it's like cancel culture it's it's all
in the same lines like you're not
allowed to learn anymore as a human you
either get it right a hundred percent
all the time through your entire past or
we're canceling you out right what I'm
saying is I think that there is some
there's some force that wants to destroy
everything we've created yeah that
that's why I consider to be evil you
know we have some problems yeah we've
got environmental problems we've got
sustainability issues okay and we've
talked about reasonable solutions like
how cool would it be if people had mini
farm everyone had a garden I love this
idea
you know peeps people who live in the
suburbs in the country could replace
their lawns with mini mini Gardens and
sustain themselves off their own food a
little bit yeah and remake cities yes
cities are designed to keep people in
control and owned essentially everybody
in a city but I'm not talking racial I
don't think it's I don't think it's
designed I think it's with how the
dominoes fell yeah you're right you're
right that's that's way more accurate
because as the life went on we just we
got bigger bigger farms to cram you we
have
if there's billions of us on this planet
now billions of us so we the our
antiquated ways are just carrying us
into the but where we are now so listen
we're getting we need a hard check we're
getting better we are getting better
yeah I mean we're improving mm-hmm the
issue is these people who are socialists
and communists want to end the system
that created wealth prosperity and fixes
these things America is a leader in
ending plastic pollution America is a
leader in reducing carbon emissions and
these people are trying to destroy the
system that created the good while
ignoring this that the people that are
exploiting it like China and India yeah
you see the things they're doing with
all their waste all their cities their
their their recklessness and even
corporations that are here and that's at
they're fighting because Trump's trying
to cut off trade to China who's the
producer in cheap goods this is that is
upping their products or their profits
so of course they're pissed they want
him out that's what he's trying to bring
us bring it back to America we were
watching this video from flex talks man
it was actually a video from see more
views which you've may have seen see
more views as a black man in the hood
Trump supporter what a boss this is look
I don't know like he was talking about
the globalist and the Illuminati and
stuff she loves me a little bit there
but this dude was walking up to young
kid you like young guys and talking to
them about how asking them some real
questions real question saying what do
you think about America what do think
about Trump and his kids are like F
America and he goes F America's that's
what you really think he's like okay we
want to go pick a country yeah and
they're like oh well and he's like nah
man nah I second America's awesome yeah
and then he was like all this stuff
they're telling you about Trump about
white people it's not true man you know
it's not true and these kids are like
yeah that's true man I know like they're
just trying to you know and then when he
met he burp a really really good point
outside event whatever his opinions are
you know in terms of Trump and in the
Illuminati he said listen these people
who tell you to hate Trump
they got their money tied up overseas it
has global industries he said I don't
like what Trump is doing and I was like
there they nailed it yeah it's not you
we're gonna talk about the Illuminati or
the globalist you can you can talk about
that if that's how you want to frame it
it's really simple man
they've got stock in foreign exchanges
they've got properties in foreign
countries
you know and Trump is saying stop
sending your manufacturing to a foreign
country and hire American workers and
they're like yeah but I'll make less
money we're not gonna make as much money
though actually it's like and is why
it's funny oh because the people love
that the people who are anti-capitalist
because they oppose exploitation are the
ones supporting open borders and
exploiting other countries there it is
not our countries we don't exploit
America we exploit other countries and
make money off of it Bernie Sanders in
2015 said that it was a coke brothers
proposal to have open borders the idea
being that if the borders are open yep
you can hire anybody you want pay him
dirt so thinking they can exploit people
here and still make a lot of profit they
can so there's there's horror stories
about what these companies do with when
when NAFTA came out and the Free Trade
Agreement Trump opposed it yeah you had
companies that would set up in they
would displace Mexican companies because
they would come in and offer slightly
more which was dramatically less and
that would devastate the local economy
and then they would pay these people
trash and then sell it back to us and it
would just create all kinds of problems
so the free trade basically meant they
could manufacture in Mexico and bring
into the US for free
Trump was like nah you want to do that
you got to pay a tariff to bring that in
and that means it's cheaper to hire
American workers which is better for our
economy right let's do it
you ever see that you do have you ever
listened that leaked audio I don't know
if it's real but it's a Ukrainian guy
and he's like listen if Hillary gets
elected it's good for us if Donald Trump
is good for America but you know we want
a good for us that's basically what he
was saying like Trump is trying to do
things that are gonna be good for
Americans all around yeah and so these
people who control industry around the
world are very much so like I don't want
to lose money you have Donald Trump yep
and it's all of these super original men
mm-hmm they got I wonder how many of
these people have investments in China
I'm sure yeah you you look at these
these these academics who are on the
take essentially lying to the federal
government for grant money and then
taking cash from China I wouldn't be
surprised if there are US politicians
who have invested in they do it in
clever way
right it'll be it'll be a holding
company in the Bahamas owned by a
Chinese nationals you know Chinese
national do you hear that Bahamas is
slowly being taken over by China I'm not
surprised
hmm every yeah everywhere dude there and
and you you look at what's going on with
China now I wouldn't be surprised when
well I'll put it this way tucker carlson
ran this segment okay where apparently
they wanted to investigate Michael Flynn
Trump's national security adviser former
because he had expressed to I think
Susan Rice that China was a bigger
threat than Russia and all of a sudden
they were like freakin we got to shut
this guy down oh yeah yeah I wonder why
think about all the companies that were
like we're sorry China and it makes you
wonder I'm not saying it's a grand
conspiracy I think over the past several
decades we've been sold out yeah through
Luke what they thought was that by doing
these deals of China China would
westernize of it instead we China eyes
yeah now we have censorship and all this
other stupid no no it's not even that
it's more like we're living in their
City we they make all of our products
yep they make all of our stuff it breaks
we need to go buy more it breaks we need
to go buy more it's just everything is
made there yeah it is yeah we got a we
need to make her I can't it's it's
getting really hard lately
they are ramping up the propaganda and
demoralization I see that the videos
that come out like I watched one video
today it was called whose side are you
on
okay and it's it's just propaganda made
by these leftists where it's everything
is the worst possible cop thing could
ever experience and go listen man I
talked about the scale prop the scaling
problem if you've got you know 30 cities
that are protesting and you've got 24
hours in a day over a week you got a lot
of opportunity to find instances that
you know the police do one or one one or
two things here or there that are
objectionable you know they need to be
called out I don't think you could ever
get to the plate get a police department
to be 100 percent perfect
yeah so that means there will always be
an opportunity for an actor to grab
enough video to put together a
compilation of police brutality and then
say see it's a problem and there's no
there's no one out there reporting the
good the good police officers
there are like no there are there it's
just to an extent I mean I'm not talking
about just maybe in this past week I'm
talking about in general like you know
think about what a good act yeah you
know you see them few and far between
but I it doesn't get the clicks I
actually thing like baby I actually
sometimes I actually think there are
more stories than my local journalists
that are positive for cops but they
don't go viral okay if a cop you know
throws you know what what like this
story right here with the the dude
getting pushed over this is it's viral
rage bait like everybody season Amelia's
in Iraq has a reaction to it but there
was there's a ton of stories that you'll
see like a cop plays basketball some
group oh yes of the video that went
viral recently of the cop doing a fakey
big flip skateboarding totally and that
all skateboarders were like going us for
and I'm like right this cop who's
skating is probably like 27 yeah he's
been skating his whole life same as
everybody else it's good and now he has
a job right and so when he sees the kids
skating he walks up he's like let me try
her board and he does a fakie big flip
which mind you is a pretty good trick
it's that switch that I was saying oh
we're just yeah we're people both humans
and oh wow crazy we got to remember that
we got to we got to do that more often I
realize we're all human I was in
Virginia and this young kid had
accidentally bumped a car in a parking
lot and scuffed it up and got panicked
did know what to do and left and he came
back to his apartment and the cops
showed up and he was having a panic
attack because it's like you just turned
a minor minor fender-bender into a
hit-and-run yeah and the cop said to him
you realize that by doing that you
turned a minor
scuffle scoff you could have just you
know it's gonna be couple under bucks
you know it would hit and run which is
serious crime and the kids freaking out
and the cop was like don't worry about
it man like no one's gonna arrest you or
anything we want to let you know all
we're gonna do is is is give the guy
your phone number and he's gonna ask you
to take care of it he's like free only
is like yeah and then the cops like
chilled and hung out while family guy
was on for like 10 15 minutes and just
just talk normal stuff like so what are
you like the guys it was young guys they
were like 28:23 30 most of the
interactions I've had with cops have
been like regular guys you know on the
job you respect if they're on the job
things are normal but I've had bad
encounters too like really bad ones
really really bad ones that me too and
if I was a stupid person I would
conflate bad people doing bad things
with other people who did nothing wrong
right and that's I think the problem
that people have when it comes to you
know propaganda and how the media plays
this game thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune into this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you